We'll start our specification
exercise in using English.
I'd like you to provide
an English language description
of the expected behavior
of y equals the sort of x.
Where x is an input sequence of integers
and y is an output sequence of integers.
And assuming that you're
sorting in ascending order.
So think how you would say
this in precise English.
>> Okay.
So, given a input vector x of integers,
we will return to y and
output vector of integers in which for
each element that is an x,
the element that comes after it
will be greater than that element.
>> You mean and why, the outcome?
>> And why, yes, yes.
So, once it's sorted, each element and
why, of the element that comes
after it will be greater than it,
except for the last element.
>> Well, first of all, say the input had
some duplicates, is it greater than, or
greater than or equal?
>> Okay so it could be greater than or
equal to if we have duplicates.
>> Okay, and
what do we do about the last one?
>> The last one will not have
a element to come after it.
>> Right.
>> So it will be the greatest element
and the, the output vector.
>> Or
possibly equal to the one before it?
>> Yes.
[LAUGH]
>> Ok.
So there's a lot going on in,
in trying to express that
in a precise fashion.
Let's see what we can,
what we can do about it.